this has been one of the longest and
most challenging investigations I've
ever been involved in is a testament to
my officers unwavering and dedicated for
sheep for justice that David Carrick has
been handed 36 life sentences today
I'm truly humbled by The Bravery of the
victims each one was prepared to live
their horrendous ordeal and face Carrick
in court
I'd also like to thank the crown
prosecution team at Thames Chilton we've
worked side by side with the exceptional
team of lawyers since October 2021
building a strong and compelling case
our investigation does not stop here
however and we've set up a special
reporting portal to allow people to
continue to share information with us
this portal will remain open and details
can be found on the Hertfordshire Police
website
I would urge anyone who thinks they've
been a victim of David Carrick it's come
forward we still want to hear from you
and we will support you
as a serving police officer David
Carrick has brought shame on the
profession and was not fit to wear the
uniform but I hope that our
determination to get Justice for the
victims in this case we'll go some way
to reassuring the public that nobody is
above the law and we will we will bring
people like David Carrick to Justice
today is about recognizing the
outstanding bravery of the victims it
often takes courage for anyone to come
forward and report a rate but in this
case to overcome the mental and physical
oppression they endured may have felt
insurmountable at times
we've heard the accounts of women who
suffered at carrick's hands
he took away their control their right
to choose their freedom
in some cases both physically and
mentally
we cannot undo the pain under anguish
that they have endured but I hope that
they can take this first step in
rebuilding their lives knowing that he
can't harm them
or any other woman
we are so grateful to every woman who
has come forward and supported this case
with each report that came in we had a
clearer picture of who Carrick was and
what he had done
the similarities between the victim
accounts detailing mental and physical
torment at the hands of the same man
were our case
we would not be where we are today
without you
the victims
taking that step forward and providing
us with a vital evidence needed to
prosecute Carrick
with your help the crown prosecution
service works with the investigation
team at Hertfordshire constabulary to
build such a strong case that Carrick
had no choice but to plead guilty
we know there are victims of other rape
and serious sexual offenses out there
and that many of you may be worried
about being believed or whether you will
ever see Justice Done
we understand these concerns and want to
reassure you that we are doing
everything that we can to improve how
these offenses are handled and we are
determined to see Justice Stone for more
victims of violence against women and
girls
we hope to encourage a prolific abuser
manipulator and rapist behind bars will
encourage other women to come forward
knowing we will do all we can to hold
the person responsible to account for
their crime
thank you